crois pas que ces pourparlers vont mener
à grand chose pour le moment c'est bien
que l'ukraine ait accepté ces
pourparlers qui sont dont les conditions
initiales étaient les conditions
devraient pour parler en lalala les
premières tentatives de pourparlers qui
ont eu lieu entre la russie l'ukraine la
russie exigeait que l'ukraine d'
insuffisante donc n'étaient pas des
vraies négociations parce que la crainte
se serait présenté qu'un fusil sur la
tempe le pour le moment il n'y a pas de
conditions ces pourparlers là donc c'est
bien que l'ukraine ait saisi cette
opportunité ça démontre sa volonté de
constructif malgré la guerre en cours
mais dans l'état actuel des choses les
pourparlers sont pareillement une
tentative pour poutine de gagner du
temps le temps de redéployer des
nouvelles ressources militaires à tout
venant de la russie en ukraine et que
l'ukraine ne sur le long terme ne
pourrait pas gagner cette guerre donc
tout c'est une tente en fait de tirer
les choses près dans une position peu
plus fort pour exiger davantage de la
part de l'ukraine lorsque les pour la
fin de ce conflit est justement alors
puisque vous parlez du temps du terrain
est-ce que les moyens que met à
disposition la communauté internationale
notamment les armes pourront faire une
quelconque différence en ukraine
absolument ça donne des jours de plus à
l'ukraine pour avoir une bonne
résistance et chaque journée quelques
années capable de résister avec force la
russie c'est des journées de plus pour
avoir une négociation où elle est en
position plus forte
je parlais il ya une install de négocier
un fusil sur la tempe c'est certain que
si l'ukraine ne plus de munitions de
plus ne serait-ce que des systèmes anti
tanks comme les messages l'hymne
américain où les laves de du royaume uni
si le grain ne risquait pas de se
défendre avec dans une position beaucoup
plus faible pour négocier donc l'ukraine
si le conflit pour se tirer dans le tas
l'ukraine a besoin d'être armé pour
lorsque les moments de négocier le
cessez le feu finale vont arriver les
graines plus est encore en bonne
position assez forte pour ne pas subir
tout simplement les conditions de la
russie